you know I i think the insurance
companies saying that they're worried
about the public health insurance option
is one of the better arguments for
having one you know the fact that they
think that this public health insurance
option is going to have to change the
way they do business is one of the
arguments for doing it because you know
if the private insurance companies were
saying oh we're not so worried you know
it's just you know it's just going to be
another you know small competitive
challenge then I'd really wonder if this
was going to provide the kind of check
on and benchmark for private insurance
companies that we need you know the you
know there is valid criticisms of having
a public health insurance plan competing
with private plans and they're all
addressed in the legislation that's been
discussed on Capitol Hill I mean my
proposal is argued for a level playing
field which means that the private and
the public health insurance plan plans
have to abide by the same rules that the
public health insurance plan can't be
funded by taxpayer dollars it has to
receive all its funds from the same
sources that the private insurance plans
receive such as the subsidies for lower
and middle-income people who get
coverage and the premiums that people
pay and finally I've argued that there
really should be strenuous efforts to
make sure that there's adequate
adjustment for plans that take on a
higher risk population in fact to me
that's one of the concerns that the
public health insurance plan is probably
going to be more attractive to people
who really need care because they want
to have a transparent plan that's going
to be there when they're sick and if
that's the case we need to really work
hard to make sure that those how the
playing field isn't tilted against the
public health insurance plan so you know
the other thing to say and I think this
is really crucial that people understand
is that what the private insurance
companies are arguing against really is
choice I mean they're arguing against
the idea that there should be
competition and people should be able to
vote with their feet between private
insurance plans and the new public
insurance plan you know the polls
suggest that people want to have that
choice but I think a lot of people are
going to choose private health insurance
plans they have name recognition they've
got decades of experience they've got
deep marketing pockets many people
associate the government with you know
poor service so it's you know the public
health insurance plan isn't going to
start out with a dominant position it
will only gain a stronger position by
convincing people that it can provide
better coverage and higher qual
lady care and ultimately isn't that I
mean what this is about healthy
competition where the private insurance
companies and the public plan are both
building on their strengths and
remedying their weaknesses you know
private insurance plans have many
virtues one there are some that they
don't have they haven't been very good
at holding down premiums they haven't
been very good at bargaining with
providers they haven't been as
innovative as they say they have been in
delivery of care I mean right now we're
talking about Medicare taking the lead
in reforming the delivery of our
healthcare system well I think that we
should have a public health insurance
plan for people younger than 65 that's
contributing to that reform as well so
to me you know the best argument for it
is the private surance companies are
worried about it because that's
precisely what we need real competition
well I think the co-op model is just a
fig leaf for people who are opposed to
the public health insurance plan and
don't want to have the blood of the
public health insurance plans demise on
their hands because the Congressional
Budget Office looked at this and said
the co-op's weren't going to make any
difference in the market I mean I'm not
against the idea of having member run
cooperative health plans there's some
wonderful plans out there like growth
group health cooperative of Puget Sound
or health partners in Minnesota but
those plans are very small and limited
and even with new federal funds is going
to be very difficult to create those
plans and have them compete effectively
against these massive private insurance
plans that dominate the market today I
mean Group Health Cooperative in Puget
Sound has a half million members and
WellPoint has something like 33 million
members so you need to have some very
serious counterweight on day one to the
private insurance plans and only a
public health insurance plan that's
linked to the Medicare program in
important respects is going to have that
so one of the things that's really
important about the house legislation is
that it creates this new public health
insurance plan in part building on the
infrastructure of Medicare it's run by
the department of health and human
services it's a federal program will be
offered nationwide you know it will not
have rates that are tied to Medicare's
rates that was a concession that was
made to get the votes necessary to pass
it but it will have the Secretary of
Health and Human Services negotiating
rates with providers and probably using
the bargaining power of this large pool
effectively to try to keep down rates so
to me you know that cooperatives are
really just a way of saying that a way
of sort of hiding opposition to the
public health insurance plan and you
know the there's only a few I think
people who seriously think they're going
to work and the one of them is Kent
Conrad of North Dakota so why they're in
legislation but I think for the most
part they don't have very strong support
either in Congress or outside it